hi i'm derek downey a developer advocate
for google cloud
in the last video i highlighted
different options for controlling the
database behavior for my banking
application that i'm deploying to cloud
spanner
in this video i'm going to show how
spanner organizes data into splits and
how that impacts the design of the
database schema
i will also highlight the tools
available in spanner for efficient
schema design and how to keep the schema
updated with online schema changes
to start cloud spanner is a row-based
relational database
spanner requires a defined schema and
supports standard sql concepts for
defining that schema
table columns must have a data type
defined
spanner supports standard scalar data
types as well as more advanced data
types to enable different application
requirements
for instance json allows storing
schema-less data within spanner
constraints foreign keys and unique
indexes help enforce the integrity of
the data
and unique and non-unique indexes help
provide faster lookups of the
data a key reason to use spanner is the
near unlimited scaling capability for
application workloads
when designing that schema it's
important to understand how spanner
organizes data to achieve the
scalability
as a horizontally scaling database
spanner automatically shards data into
splits
splits enables spanner to scale by
distributing compute capacity to
multiple servers
but how do these splits affect the
design decisions for my schema
for a quick example from my banking app
i have a customers table with a customer
id as primary key
a common pattern in many relational
databases is to increment an integer for
new rows
with data splits sequential keys are an
anti-pattern because your last split
will receive all new rows creating a
hotspot
ideally the primary key should be
inserted in random order so inserts hit
multiple splits which improves right
scaling
common methods to get random order
inserts are uuid version 4 or generating
hash keys
splits also have implications for
related data in other tables
in my app a customer can have multiple
accounts
the accounts data could end up in a
different split than the customer it
belongs to
if i have a query to get a customer and
their accounts spanner will have to get
data from multiple splits
this increases request latency
especially if the splits are processed
by different servers
to avoid this tables can be interleaved
together in the schema definition
if i interleave accounts into the
customers table
then the account rows will be located in
the same split as the customer they
belong to and make my query faster
keep in mind that interleaving cannot be
changed for existing tables
and not all table relationships should
be interleaved
interleaving should be used for related
data that is frequently accessed
together
splits also affect indexes because
spanner implements indexes as tables
internally
so requesting more columns than an index
provides can result in getting data from
multiple splits
creating an index that stores columns
that are typically requested by queries
can solve this
in my app the unique username index also
stores the password
so a login query that searches for a
combination of username and password
will be done efficiently
the last thing to highlight about
spanner schema design is that schema
changes are online
so your application can continue reading
and writing to the table during the
change
the time to complete a change depends on
the type of change
adding a new column that doesn't have a
default value will complete quickly
since there's nothing to do for existing
rows
adding a new column or modifying an
existing column with a default value
requires backfilling data into each
existing row of the table
modifying an existing column with a new
constraint such as not null will require
data validation
data validation and backfilling
operations take longer to complete
but spanner will process this in the
background so that your users and
applications are not impacted
this makes schema changes painless
as a relational database spanner
requires a defined schema using
supported data types constraints and
indexing
but it makes it as easy as possible to
change later as data requirements change
data in spanner is automatically sharded
into splits that can be powered by
different compute nodes to achieve great
scalability
splits require different schema design
choices than traditional relational
database systems
and i've shown how to avoid hot spotting
and how to interleave related data
together so query requests are handled
efficiently in the final video i will
show how our banking app uses both
standard dml statements and spanner
mutations to write to our spanner
database
[Music]
you